mike deux filles la star des
conservateurs
chassé du sénat en novembre 2013
humilié discréditer
il y régnait presque depuis son
assermentation en janvier 2009
la vedette du journalisme politique
canadien depuis trois décennies est
devenu du jour au lendemain un des grand
meneur de claques du premier ministre
ces politiques aussi à l'autre il a
rempli les salles et les coques du parti
conservateur
les militants l'adorait jusqu'au jour
mais que ça ne doivent que tout a
basculé propre avocat dira plus tard il
était le plus grand atout du parti
conservateur
il est devenu son pire bull est tombé à
l'origine du scandale une technicalité
sur les règles de résidence du sénat et
le remboursement des dépenses du
sénateur à ottawa et sur la route à
transmettre la bonne parole
conservatrice voilà pour les chefs
d'accusation d'abus de confiance et de
fraude totalisant plus de 200 mille
dollars
mais il ya plus c'est la claque aux de
vie politique car en voulant sauver son
sénateur vedette du guêpier le chef de
cabinet du premier ministre un peu lui a
c'est 90 mille dollars d'où l'accusation
la plus explosive
celle de corruption monsieur doit fille
est accusée
un chef de corruption de fonctionnaires
judiciaires dès qu'il a été nommé
sénateur de l'île-du-prince-édouard sa
province natale
mike duffy a choisi de désigner sa
résidence de cavendish comme étant sa
résidence principale
et de réclamer ainsi des allocations de
déplacement et de repas chaque fois
qu'il était à ottawa dans la maison
qu'il occupait déjà depuis de nombreuses
années
facture totale plus de trente quatre
mille dollars même les enquêteurs
externe du sénat ont concédé que les
règles sur ce que constituent les
résidences principales et de résidences
secondaires n'étaient pas clairs
l'époque le sénat semblent eux-mêmes lui
avoir confirmé par écrit dès 2009 que le
fait de pas habiter l'île du prince
édouard était acceptable
le problème fera valoir son avocat en
cours
ce n'est pas le sénateur deux filles ce
sont les règles tel que rédigé à
l'époque et ça ne s'arrête pas là on
reproche également à mike duffy d'avoir
facturé au sénat
le nombreux déplacements pour les
activités partisanes pour le compte du
parti conservateur
la preuve démontrera que mon client n'a
rien fait de mal répond l'avocat de mike
de fille mais cette affaire dépasse le
cadre légal au coeur de la tempête
les documents d'un quai de la grc et
révèle plutôt que dans les couloirs du
sénat
au bureau du premier ministre les
conseillers il est proche de stephen un
peu ont déployé d'immenses énergie pour
minimiser
porter les enquêtes externes tout en
cherchant à convaincre mme avec deux
filles de rembourser les sommes exigées
pour enterrer la sphère déjà le chef de
cabinet de stephen un peu près santé de
fear
soyons clairs je crois que tout ça va
mal se terminer
écrivez-nous joe wright dans un courriel
6 février
alors qu'en public mike de fille disait
faire amende honorable en s'engageant
pour rembourser pour tourner la page
on apprendra que le sénateur wingles
chine a plutôt été sollicité pour payer
la facture à même les fonds du parti
conservateur
j'ai le feu vert premier ministre
l'écrivain est joe wright au sujet du
stratagème
ça c'est quand la facture semblait être
de 32 mille dollars
mais quand elle a grimpé 90000 tout
s'est écroulé
exaspérés c'est là que chef de cabinet
de stephen un peu nadja est millionnaire
a décidé de payer personnellement la
traite bancaire de 90 mille dollars
les gens font pas des chèques de 90
mille dollars comme ça sans raison
valable position de la surface et que
et quand le fameux devrait être
remboursé des missions congédiement la
version du premier ministre a changé au
fil du temps que directive parce que le
premier ministre donne est à nous ou à
d'autres membres de son cabinet et
savait steven un peu près faire cette
décision qui a pris ses responsabilités
lorsque le premier ministre affirme et à
l'ensemble des canadiens en sept chars
que personne d'autre dans son bureau on
était au courant du paiement des 90
dollars à mike duffy est ce qu'on vit à
dire c'était faux on sait maintenant que
moi et trois conseillers du premier
ministre était au courant des
tractations pour camoufler la faire
l'argentier du parti aussi et que 13
autres personnes dont plusieurs
sénateurs ont été impliqués mike duffy a
fini par briser son silence que froide
acculés au pied du mur chassé du sénat
par ses fers
l'ancien enfant chéri du parti
conservateur à régler ses comptes
m
et le choc au cours des prochaines
semaines l'ancien chef de cabinet n'a
joe wright qui a toujours gardé le
silence
l'avocat conseil du premier ministre à
l'époque sénateur conservateur certains
députés et autres seront tous appelés à
la barre des témoins déjà en novembre
l'avocat de mike duffy avertissait que
ce qu'on sait de cette affaire n'est que
la pointe de l'iceberg
quelles sont ces révélations inédites
risque-t-elle à nouveau d'ébranler le
premier ministre cette fois ci plus
d'échappatoire sous serment les plus
loyaux serviteurs de stephen harper
seront forcés de lever le voile sur les
intrigues qui ont mobilisé la machine
politique conservatrice pendant plus de
six mois
le procès de mike duffy pourrait bien
aussi être le procès des tactiques
politiques de ce premier ministre de son
entourage de son gouvernement
et